l'éloquence britannique c'est plus une
éloquence du débat qu une éloquence
véritablement du discours elle s'inscrit
pas dans une dimension de rupture mais
on sent quand même qu'elle n'a pas
forcément envie de jouer les seconds
couteaux et qui a une ambition derrière
on
me paye on
compare beaucoup lit strauss à margaret
thatcher et c'est vrai qu'elle n'a pas
l'air particulièrement dérangés par
cette comparaison elle s'inscrit dans
cette idée sur ce discours en
particulier on voit que c'est pas
forcément encore une oratrice nez aux
makes the kingdom of
freedom
son débit est quand même très rapide
elle passe assez vite d'un point à un
autre alors que margaret thatcher elle
avait véritablement une empreinte vocale
beaucoup plus lente une exécution assez
particulière un débit qui lui aussi
était à celle enfin vous parler
lentement c'est que vous n'avez pas peur
qu'on vous interrompre a priori
touché margaret thatcher transpirait
vraiment l'autorité mais il faut quand
même savoir qu'elle avait aussi beaucoup
beaucoup travailler sa voix en amont qui
n'était pas forcément la même que quand
elle a commencé la politique pour la
rendre justement plus profonde et plus
autoritaire et pour le moment c'est vrai
que les strauss elle elle en est pas
encore tout à fait là après margaret
thatcher elle est aussi connue pour ses
punchlines qui sont restés dans
l'histoire notamment sur les hommes et
les femmes on le disait sur le
communisme aussi
istres est elle pour l'instant elle
inclut des formules dans son discours
mais qui sont pas forcément très très
efficace elle ce sur quoi elle insiste
véritablement c'est le mot delivered
c'est vraiment un mot qu'elle utilise un
petit peu à toutes les sauces à voter en
zone médiane jss le
jan hernych as we hope et aux nations
unies portes le
5 e
[Applaudissements]
l'éloquence britannique c'est plus une
éloquence du débat qu une éloquence
véritablement du discours donc ça sera
intéressant surtout de voir ce que les
stress va donner face à l'opposition à
la chambre des communes parce que si par
exemple on prend theresa may theresa may
n'a pas fait véritablement de discours
qui soit restée dans les mémoires mais
en revanche elle a eu des passes d'armes
qui était vraiment mémorable est très
très incisive à la chambre des communes
notamment gens pensent je pense à une
face à jeremy corbyn
[Applaudissements]
il
est temps de jeu
on
[Applaudissements]
donc voilà pouvoir océan débat avec
l'opposition en face ce que ça va
pouvoir donner pour se donner
véritablement une idée de ce que lorsque
le stress va donner du moins à l'oral
[Musique]
5 elle termine son discours donc par
cette phrase qui rappelle d'un
évidemment si vous préférez eyes and
determined to deliver 5 kg ou donc si
avec tout ça elle délivre pas à la fin
c'est vrai que c'est un peu à n'y rien
comprendre
[Musique]